Those that have the Atelier Robin machine, the picture that you see here is these little
beads, these little clip-on things on wires. You've all seen these, you have electrical
devices that have these not as big as these because these wires are thick, but your computer probably
has it. Your computer cord has it. Your different charging cords might have all sorts of
electronical device have these things. They're called ferrite cords or ferrite beads.
I put a video about them on the frequency cords, on the first module and the frequency
course explaining that what ferrite beads do, or ferrite cords, cords, C-O-R-E-S,
what they do is they help mitigate electrostatic electricity. When you run electricity through
cords, some of that could be dispersed out as electromagnetic frequencies. Some of it can
happen. A cord, especially in its running frequencies, can pick up static electricity in your home.
It can create static electricity in your home. It can pick up radio frequencies in your home.
And it can end up damaging devices. That's why a lot of electronics will have these ferrite cords
that are, many of them are built into the wire, so they're like encased in the wire. So it just
looks like a little bump in your wire. You probably don't even notice them now that I'm speaking of
this. You might go, oh, I see that on this cord or that cord that I have. They're very common,
and they're there. They're made up of ferrite of an iron, and it's there to reduce
static electricity, and it's there to prevent any damage to electronics and to reduce loss
in the conductivity. I remember years ago where we lived in a place where our phone wasn't
real receptive, you know, our phone. And we had to, the phone company sent out these little
things that you'd clip on the wires, and it would help prevent that static electricity that the phone
would come in much clearer. That's what these things are. So understand that we are putting these on
all of the bulbs to the connection area, and then to right up by the bulb, you can't really see
it in this picture. It's up there in the filter. I didn't take a very good picture of that. So there's
actually four on each bulb. So it's on the cord. It's two right by where you'd connected it to the
right, but she didn't two up by the bulb. We're doing this on all the new bulbs that were sent
out. And it's more important on, it would be good to have these on your true right bulbs and things
to help protect the equipment and help clean up the frequencies that are being sent to the bulb.
But it's more important with the artillery Robin because the artillery Robin is, you know,
running at three times the voltage. So you're getting a lot more voltage going through those wires,
a lot more ability to pick up static radio frequencies, and could, you know, feed back to the
machine. Anybody who's old to write, true right, or you know, the new people that have a
artillery Robin, probably haven't experienced this yet. But for years, people have said,
I'm running the right thing and it's something weird with the program. It's running the bulb,
but the timer on the timing down the program isn't working or it's timing up or it's being goofy.
It's because the frequencies, you're running frequencies through this bulb. And if your bulb is too
close to the computer, it can make your computer go goofy. And it can throw off whatever you're running
on the computer. And if you're currently just running the right program, which you're supposed to
be only running on your right computer, it can throw off that timer on there. And, you know, people
can get all upset. Well, it's running. The bulb is running, but it's the timer isn't working. Okay,
that's why we haven't told you to not look at that. You're supposed to hit and run your computer,
and you're supposed to close the laptop for multiple reasons. Number one, you don't want any EMS
from your laptop. So as soon as you hit run of your computer for both the artillery Robin and the
true right, it sends the program that you hit run on it sends that program to the machine. You can
literally pull the USB cable out. You can take the computer in the other room. The computer is doing
nothing except you lose the commands in the computer. In this case, you wanted to hit stop or pause
or case you wanted to, oh, that was a wrong program. You hit stop and you go back to do something else.
But if you hit the right program and hit run, you're supposed to close the computer. So you're not
getting any A, you're not getting any EMS from the computer and B, you're not getting any feedback
from the frequencies that you're running because you are running these very powerful frequencies
can affect your computer. This is why we also tell you not to run. It's better if you're not using
your cell phone while you're running your right either because sometimes your cell phone will start
acting goofy and things, especially if you're running frequencies that specifically can affect your phone.
Understand frequencies are waves. So think of it this way. Anything that's running frequencies,
which is any electronic device, including your folder, your laptop is producing frequencies.
You're producing very specific frequencies via light through the right machine.
What you're doing, so think of it this way. It's like if you're standing at a very still
pod and you throw a pebble in the pod, pebble hits and waves go out all directions from that pebble.
But now at the same time, you throw that pebble, you throw another pebble and it lands 20 inches away
from that. And now these waves hit these waves that intersect, affect each other. And they can
cancel out each other if they're at the same frequency, meaning the exact same size pebble.
And they hit at the same time, they could literally there, you know, the wave theory of physics,
it could cancel out each other, it could affect each other. Now you're not going to cancel out the
frequencies from the right machine, but you can affect your cell phone. You could affect
your computer and things. So that's why we tell you to close your computer and it's best not to use
your cell phone. So the benefit of using the fair-eyed beads is that you're not also picking up static
electricity or dirty electricity from your house that could damage your bone, that could damage
your machine, or could affect possibly the quality of the frequencies that you're trying to run through
the ball. So we just started doing this. So if you're like, well, I don't have those on my ball,
we're going to be sending them out to people and I know we didn't put it on it, but I may cross over
because I just started doing this a few weeks ago and you might have a bomb that has it on there
and you might get it envelope from us with these in there that you're like, I already have them.
So just keep them. So, hey, I'll do them. If you have a true right, and you're listening to me,
and you want to add these, you can. We have to charge you for them. They cost us money. You don't
really need them. You've been doing it without for a year or two, but you can buy them. They're
fairly cheap on Amazon. They're nine millimeter, fair-eyed cores. You can buy a pack of them for
$10 and put them on your equipment. You're good to have really all your equipment, any electronic
equipment, television, anything. It couldn't protect against surges and things. They're beneficial,
so something to think about. The question related to this is, running my right by the generator
or inverter. Yes, okay. Yes, you're still getting 110 volts of electricity, 120
volts of electricity, and if you can power up your machine, then you couldn't run the rice.
Yep, no problem. And then did I understand you to say that once we closed the laptop after
turning the right program out, and we don't need to be concerned about the EMS or the laptop,
that's correct. Yep. And I do have a video that's how your laptop doesn't produce that much EMS
radiation, most to what your cell phone produces. But still, it's better to close it,
because once you close your laptop, it'll go to sleep and it won't be running. You also should
have your laptop on airplane mode. In case I messed up and didn't do that, when I sent it to you,
I always try to remember to switch it to airplane mode before I send it to you. If you have your
laptop on airplane mode, then it won't be trying to pick up an IP address in your home. So,
it won't be searching for that. It's going to produce a lot less EMS as well.
As you see, the entire care hurts one at a separate time from the right interferes
with the treatment, right treatment. So, you're talking about a different device. No, it doesn't
interfere with the right treatment. If you're using a tear care one or if you're using a PEMF,
you can do that. The difference is, you're using light frequencies and a totally different
frequency range. Any PEMF type device is using frequencies that about literally one to ten
hurts versus, you know, you can see the hurts value of your frequencies with marries anywhere between
30 and 30,000 hurts. So, you're not going to have any effect on that frequency.
And then I'll finish this last question on here. Have you been reading? I've been reading that
milk distal is not good for hormone positive breast cancer. If you have a question about that,
would hot-cut be better? So, milk distal is usually used to help support phase one and two,
phase two, mainly phase one detoxification pathways in the liver. Can there be an interruption
with hormone positive breast cancer? There's some data about that. Also,
there's some data about adaptogens, possibly being in an interference with breast cancer,
hormone positive breast cancers. This is really the ashwaganda is the issue, not so much the other
adaptogens. Yeah, if you want to be absolutely protected, there's other ways to support those pathways
and certainly if you wanted to switch to tonka, that is another way to help support your liver pathways.